der kabinettstisch von olaf scholz der
fühlt sich in diesen minuten auf dem
tisch der koalitionsvertrag in drei
stunden stellt die ampel den feierlich
vor sie werden live dabei sein und drum
herum nach diesen nächtlichen
verhandlungen hier nochmal die
dramatischen bilder dieses krimis sind
der schlacht um die macht in den letzten
12 jahre 24 stunden drumherum um den
kabinettstisch all die frischen neuen
minister stühle und die fühlen sich eben
jetzt nach und nach ein stuhl nach dem
anderen vergeben die ministerliste der
neuen ampel koalition jetzt hier live
bei bild mit unserem bild vizekanzler
sozusagen paul ronzheimer hier im studio
also fangen wir mal ganz vorne an was
wissen wir olaf scholz ist kanzler okay
nicht das ganz grosse geheimnis wird
kanzler aber was welche namen können wir
schon jetzt dass olaf scholz kanzler
wird kein patricia das ist keine
überraschung mehr das stimmt was ein
bisschen eine überraschung ist ist die
klarheit mit der wir schon sagen können
was bei der fdp und bast bei den grünen
passiert also wissen los robert habeck
wird vizekanzler und zwar für klima
wirtschaft wirtschaft klima also für die
wichtigen strategischen fragen der
grünen das wird robert habeck übernehmen
annalena baerbock in klammern ich komme
aus dem völkerrecht sie wird
außenministerin darum was sie sich immer
geträumt hat das wollte sie man hat sie
hier keinen unseren interviews auch
immer so wahrgenommen wenn zum außen
gingen ja da wollte sie mit reden und
sie hat ihr ziel erreicht sie hat den
außenposten bekommen bei der fdp
spannend kristalina hat sein ziel
erreicht er wird finanzminister da hat
es gekracht er wurde gerungen den
letzten tagen den letzten wochen um
dieses amt aber christian lindner
bekommt es er wird finanzminister das
sind die wichtigsten posten erst mal
zusammengefasst die fdp ansonsten
bekommt noch justiz die fdp bekommt
bildung und die grünen bekommen neben
neben außen neben wirtschaft unter
anderem natürlich was ist natürlich aber
klassisch familie
verkehr geht an die fdp das eine
überraschung da hatte ich gedacht dass
anton hofreiter zum beispiel
verkehrsminister werden könnte ein
treuer heute auch selbst mit ihm schon
sprechen können dann hat er die ganze
zeit gesagt mit der anton hofreiter der
wird demnächst hier mein büro übergeben
hatte angepackt
ja ich glaube so ein paar autofahrer da
draußen werden aufatmen das ist nicht
anton hofreiter wird ist allerdings da
kann man sagen das ist doch eine der
überraschungen bislang aus dem ampel
kabinett jetzt haben wir noch ein
bisschen für uns nicht mehr lange 15 uhr
dann wird alles präsentiert was passiert
jetzt du bist nicht alleine gekommen ein
handy ist dabei was passiert jetzt in
diesen entscheidenden stunden wo er noch
so ein bisschen was geschraubt und
gedreht werden kann ja da sind die
letzten absprachen ich habe gerade mit
einigen sprechen können da wird wurde
heute nacht teilweise nur einen
anderthalb stunden geschlafen ja nachts
ging es nach hause dann wieder rein weil
man sozusagen an den letzten details des
vertrags werken musste spannend bei der
spd man will die minister nahmen noch
für sich behalten und warten bis zum
parteitag denn da wird sich na ja da
wird sich bekriegt kann man sagen
zwischen den landesverbänden wer bekommt
was spannend auch das
gesundheitsministerium geht an die spd
als der wichtigsten ämter in dieser zeit
haben wir nicht beliebt an die sp an die
spd das ist das was der neueste stand
ist und das spannende ist wir hören es
könnte eben nicht karl lauterbach werden
sondern der den proporz gründen
sozusagen eine frau werden das ist noch
nicht ganz klar die namen sind noch
nicht genau verteilt auf das
verteidigungsministerium geht an die spd
da wird auch spannend zu sehen sein da
hört man verschiedene nahmen unter
anderem auch also aus meiner sicht einen
überraschenden dass auch heiko maas
wieder gehandelt wird also der jetzige
außenminister
und hier sieht man gerade mal die alten
das ist sozusagen die truppe die sich
dann heute verabschiedet hat letzte
kabinettssitzung dass die geschichte des
tages heute mit angela merkel unter
stehen dann ein paar minister und
ministerinnen dabei die man wieder sehen
wird nämlich in der mitte zum beispiel
christine lambrecht rechtsträger dh
links vorne olaf scholz sowieso also das
sind die namen die sich noch mal rüber
retten die wenigen der spd so sieht's
aus vor lamprecht hatte eigentlich auch
mit dem karriere-ende schon gerechnet
die justizministerin die wir in den
letzten jahren erlebt haben sie wird
gehandelt zumindest als mögliche
innenministerin das geht nämlich auch an
die spd und wir haben darüber dass hall
gesehen der wird wohl sehr
wahrscheinlich das bundesministerium für
arbeit behalten muss sich also nicht
großartig verändern kann also alle
kisten da wo sie sind stehen lassen und
macht weiter da wo er aufgehört hat
macht weiter da wo er aufgehört hat so
genanntes kernressort für die spd da
geht es um rente arbeit mindeste und all
diese dinge wichtiges ressort auch für
die nächsten jahre das ist einmal über
die geschichte des tages sprechen über
annalena baerbock das wird diskussionen
auslösen bei uns im land annalena
baerbock die neue bundes außenministerin
in der tradition von joschka fischer
aber mensch nach all den debatten um
ihre person gibt es jetzt einen
absoluten top job in der regierung und
vor allen dingen wir haben so viel auch
familiär immer von ihr gehört welche
rolle die familie spielt und so weiter
sie wird noch mehr nicht zu hause sein
das ist schon eine spannende geschichte
dieses tages paul was hast du da für
reaktionen auch von dem künftigen
kabinettskollegen auf diese personalie
das spannende ist was man in den tagen
vor der entscheidung gehört hat da haben
nämlich ihre gegnerinnen und gegner so
viele gibt es bei den grünen nicht aber
wo anders gesagt naja die kann ja gar
nicht so viel reisen die hat ja keine
kinder da kann man nicht mehr unterwegs
sein das wurde ins feld geführt aber
annalena baerbock willst trotzdem machen
sie traut sich das zu und wenn ich
annalena baerbock in letzten jahren
getroffen habe mit ihr gesprochen habe
auch im hintergrund so heißt es zwischen
journalisten und politikern dass man
nicht das schreibt oder direkt schreibt
oder ein interview führt da habe ich
immer gespürt außenpolitik das ist ihre
passion sie ist sozusagen
erinnere ich mich in den nord irak
gereist damals hat sich um die jesiden
gekümmert das ist ihr thema dann ist sie
tatsächlich hatte fest ich wiederhole
noch mal diese berühmte auftritt
zusammen mit robert habeck ja ich komme
aus dem völkerrecht und du bist ja ich
glaube da ging es um um landwirtschaft
an bei ihm er wird nicht
landwirtschaftsminister hat mich meine
beine bauer genau um schweinebauern also
das war in den koalitionsverhandlungen
hört man von anfang an klar dass sie
klar gemacht hat ich will außenminister
werden und sonst gar nichts die kinder
haben ja noch ein vater und der hat ja
auch schon unterstützung an gesichert
gerne zugesichert ganz früh im wahlkampf
als hier noch das ziel hat der kanzlerin
zu werden da der ja schon ganz klar
gesagt nicht zurück jetzt gesagt ich
halte ihr den rücken frei ja er war
vorher als lobbyist im politischen
berlin unterwegs und hat dann direkt
sozusagen auch zum anfang gesagt ich
gehe da raus und kümmere mich jetzt mehr
um die familie das wird er jetzt noch
mehr tun müssen dann natürlich muss man
als außenministerin reisen aber da doch
eine ganz spannende frage dazu die
außenministerin und der künftige kanzler
die stehen bei ganz vielen
außenpolitischen fragen sehr weit
auseinander zum beispiel die frage wie
gehen wir mit russland um wie gehen wir
mit china um was passiert im künftig in
der migrationsfrage also auch da
spannendes thema was ist mit belarus
polen da hat olaf scholz gesagt er
versteht polen mehr oder weniger dass
sie deine mauerbau da ist anna lena
berger ganz anders gepolt das werden
spannende auseinandersetzung werden wie
erlebst du diese stunden diese unfassbar
spannenden politische stunden hier in
berlin wenn du mit den künftigen
minister spricht jetzt vor allen dingen
bei den grünen und bei der fdp das sind
ja momente im moment die verändern leben
hier wird aus einem jahr relativ
einfachen abgeordneten leben ein ja noch
bedeutendere es wichtigeres amt ein
minister leben plötzlich verändert sich
alles absolut und da sind gerade bei der
fdp politiker dabei die hat man jetzt so
nicht auf der straße erkennen würde man
so nicht auf der straße erkennen
natürlich christian lindner erkennen
viele in deutschland lange dabei über
zehn jahre schon 2011 generalsekretär
aber ein herr buschmann ich glaube den
würde man so nicht erkennen der jetzt
justizminister werden soll volker
wissing auch schon ein bisschen drin als
generalsekretär sollte jetzt
verkehrsminister werden auch ein ganz
wichtiger posten das wird auch spannend
zu sehen sein wie kommt da klima bei den
grünen und die fdp mit den auto themen
und der wirtschaft wie knallt das was
passiert da also da ist ganz ganz viel
musik finde ich glaube man muss eins
sagen kein und patricia die krönung
seiner karriere
die legt in diesen minuten in diesen
stunden christian lindner hin der mann
den alle ausgelacht haben nach dem
letzten mal als er gesagt hat besser
nicht regieren als schlecht regieren als
er sozusagen das aufgebrochen hat dann
mit der fdp nach unten gerauscht wir
erinnern uns als herr kemmerich damals
ministerpräsident werden wollte in
zürich da stand er bundesweit nur mal
bei 56 prozent und dann durch corona
durch die freiheits dem wieder nach oben
und jetzt ist er dort wo er immer
hinwollte finanzminister das ist schon
eine unglaubliche geschichte es war für
ihn aber auch kein einfacher weg spricht
es an aber auch in den verletzte
vergangenen wochen war es kein einfacher
weg den er gab's ja ordentlich reibung
zwischen den grünen und der fdp da ging
es einmal um das ministerium klima und
wirtschaft einmal um das ministerium
finanzen und da waren sich alle da habe
ich nicht ganz so grün beide wollen das
finanzministerium robert habeck hat
gesagt ich will es und christian lindner
hat gesagt ich will es daran hätte das
ganze zerbrechen können und dann ist
robert habe offenbar irgendwann in den
verhandlungen das muss man so sagen die
lange lange ganz ganz geheim gehalten
wurden eingeknickt und hat dann gesagt
okay christian lindner kann es machen
ich kriege dann ein superministerium mit
wirtschaft mit klima die wichtigen
themen christian lindner hatte ja ein
taktisch sehr klugen zug gemacht in den
vergangenen jahrhunderten gesagt naja
robert wenn du finanzminister werden
willst dann holen wir als fdp aber klima
ja also was was wir dann los gewesen bei
den grünen in der basis wenn das
plötzlich an die fdp gegangen wäre das
war schon sehr strategisch kluger
schachzug von kristallen das können
sozusagen die stars in der neuen
regierung sein auf der einen seite
finanzminister christian lindner auf der
anderen seite der wirtschafts und
klimaminister robert habeck und
dazwischen wird das für olaf scholz
wahrscheinlich auch nicht ganz einfach
sein das dann zusammenbinden zwischen
diesen beiden ja charismatischen typen
dazu noch annalena baerbock eben als
frau als junge frau im außenministerium
das muss man erst mal zusammen binden
können vielleicht hat es deswegen in der
vergangenen nacht so lange gedauert da
ging es ja noch mal richtig rund peter
tiede sie haben gerade schon im bild
gesehen auf den spuren davon christian
lindner der war den ganzen abend die
ganzen nachmittag die ganze nacht auf
den spuren der koalitionäre und hatte
eben auch ganz beeindruckende eindrücke
hinter den kulissen gesammelt von diesen
entscheidenden minuten in der schlacht
um die macht
es ist der final countdown die letzten
stunden auf dem weg an die macht die
ampel ringt um ihrem koalitionsvertrag
ihren deutschland viel aus diesem self
wird nach acht wochen eine regierung das
bild protokoll dieses politik grammys es
ist kurz nach elf am dienstagvormittag
die spitzenrunde trifft sich in der spd
zentrale
fast alle kommen durch die tiefgarage
nur christian lindner ab 12 wird
verhandelt jedes team hat seine eigenen
räume im willy brandt haus für
geheimabsprachen nach viereinhalb
stunden die ampel verhandler bekommen
eine kaffeemaschine und einen großen
kühlschrank jetzt ist klar das wird
später immer wieder zigarettenpausen
jetzt gelingt bild der blick hinter die
kulissen der künftige kanzler olaf
scholz mit seinem wichtigsten
geldexperten
finanzstaatssekretär jörg cookies ein
bild das zeigt wo es noch knirscht es
geht um kohle 17 uhr plötzlich
aufbruchstimmung die noch kanzlerin ruft
die ampel muss zum corona krisentreffen
ins kanzleramt scholz blind berbalk und
harbeck links ist es dunkel geworden um
18 uhr 32 verlässt die am
bundeskanzleramt zurück in die
spd-zentrale wieder verhandlungen 20 uhr
39 die ampel lässt sich pizza liefern
rucola und eine prise oder wieder
vergehen stunden ist in die nacht es ist
zwanzig nach 1 als das grünen team das
willy brandt haus verlässt
um 2.15 macht auch olaf scholz
feierabend wenig später sein engster
vertrauter wolfgang schmidt noch steht
sie nicht die ampel noch einmal ist
deutschland ohne neue regierung
aufgewacht der final countdown
er geht in die verlängerung
ja das war also die nacht und um 15 uhr
da werden wir ganz genau wissen wer
übernimmt welche posten was steht drin
im koalitionsvertrag wir schauen uns
jetzt schon mal an was wir wissen wer
welche politischen positionen übernehmen
wird da geht es ans große köpfe rücken
und das machen jetzt teilweise im polanc
immer
ja danke patricia paul ronzheimer unser
bild vizekanzler hat hier alle köpfe mal
mitgenommen alle die in der verlosung
sozusagen sind das sind mehr köpfe als
stühle das kennen wir ja vom
kindergeburtstag und jetzt muss man sich
ganz schnell hinsetzen und die einen
oder anderen wurden eben schon gesetzt
einer hat sich zuerst natürlich ein
gesetz olaf scholz klar bundeskanzler
jetzt müssen wir einen namen ein
bisschen erklären denn der ist auch
gesetzt hier das war eigentlich auch nie
strittig das ist wolfgang schmidt den tu
ich mal ganz in die nähe von wolf von
von olaf scholz vielleicht den kanzler
ein bisschen höher als wolfgang schmidt
aber wer ist der mann und welchen posten
bekommt er das ist der engste man von
olaf scholz der strippenzieher der macht
der mann der olaf scholz zu dem gemacht
hat der ist ich glaube ohne wolfgang
schmidt es nicht geschafft und er wird
chef des bundeskanzleramtes er gilt als
einer der besten strippenzieher
tatsächlich im politischen berlin er hat
schon seit 22 jahren ist er durch berlin
gelaufen werk gesagt nein wir schaffen
das wir kriegen eine ampel und dann
haben ihn alle ausgelacht und am ende
hat er gelacht jetzt lachen die beiden
und ganz spannend ist ja dass die beiden
hier waren bisher finanzen und jetzt
wackeln die einmal rüber hier gemeinsam
ins kanzleramt also spätestens am ich
glaube siebter dezember ist jetzt
aktuell das datum wo dann vereidigt
werden könnte und es zieht jemand neues
ins finanzministerium ein und das ist
auch keine allzu große überraschung aber
daneben natürlich auch ein besonderer
moment wenn es steht also christian
lindner neuer bundesfinanzminister
christian lindner neuer
bundesfinanzminister ist ein großer
traum wird wahr das was er schon immer
wollte seinen traum posten aber er
musste lange kämpfen kann denn ein
anderer wollte diesen posten auch
robert habeck ihres robert habeck der
mann jetzt habe ich die falsche hier ist
robert habeck und er kommt stattdessen
hierhin k ins wirtschaftsministerium
aber nicht nur wirtschaft da müssen wir
noch klima darunter stracke das machen
wir auch direkt ja also ergänzen wir
hier einmal in geld und in etwas
wackeligen buchstaben schreibe ich hier
einmal in meine besten schul schrift so
wie man das sieht ja jetzt schon wieder
gelöscht machen wir nochmal dazu ja noch
nötig halte und klima also ganz wichtig
das ministerium wird größer als das von
peter altmaier und nicht nur da es
robert habe wird vizekanzler das was
bild am sonntag damals als allererstes
berichtet hat das ist offenbar ein deal
gab zwischen robert habe und er hier
nämlich die ihr hier annalena baerbock
sie nämlich als die schwimmer hirscher
auswärtiger da ist sie da wollte sie hin
aber sie hat gesagt schon vor der wahl
offenbar wenn ich die wahl verliere wenn
ich nicht kanzlerin werde dann wirst du
robert vizekanzler und so läuft es jetzt
würdest du sagen das ist noch ein
absoluter top job weil offenbar wollte
robert habeck diesen job ja nicht haben
gilt das als absoluter top job im moment
noch das außenministerium es ist vor
allem einem job wo man beliebt werden
kann oder wieder belebt werden kann denn
das braucht sie sie muss wieder
irgendwie beliebt werden und es liegt
ihr sie hat da immer eine passion gehabt
sie ist durch die welt gereist ihr
themen ihre themen sind außen sich sehr
um den irak gekümmert um russland um
china das sind die themen wo sie hin
will aber natürlich keine erst recht
eigentlich wird die wirkliche
außenpolitik hier viel gelernt jetzt
schnappen wir uns einen der bisher noch
nicht so vielleicht in aller munde ist
marco buschmann der war immer wieder zu
sehen in den verhandlungen fdp der
schatten von christian lindner sozusagen
in den verhandlungen wurde habe ich den
hin schieben wo kommt der handy marco
buschmann wird justizminister
er war vorher parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer
es gab auch spekulationen ob er
möglicherweise als stellvertreter von
christa länder ins finanzministerium
also staatssekretär ziehen könnte weil
das finanzministerium ist natürlich
jetzt nicht so auf die fdp ausgerichtet
aber marco buschmann bekommt einen
posten justiz sehr sehr wichtiger posten
in der aktuellen regierung jetzt sieht
das alles schon so ganz gut aus so
langsam füllt sich das roberto sei
bisher minister für arbeit und soziales
also unser renten minister zum beispiel
der wird das sitzenbleiben einfach davon
gehen wir aus das ist aber noch nicht
festgelegt das spannende fdp und grüne
geben ihre ministerien die minister
nahmen heute bekannt die spd will warten
und sagt erst nach dem parteitag denn da
gibt es gerangel so viele ministerposten
die landesverbände gibt es nämlich nicht
und olaf scholz hat angekündigt zur
hälfte frauen zur hälfte männer und da
könnte einer zum opfer fallen carla den
deutschland kennt einige lieben ihre
mögen nicht so karl lauterbach der
beginn von eigentlich hierhin also
zumindest wenn man ihn selber fragt und
auch ziemlich viele millionen deutsch er
kämpft um das gesundheitsministerium an
charakter aus den hintergründen wie er
telefoniert wie heran will wie es
unbedingt machen will aber olaf kayser
bei andere sind vorsichtiger es ist noch
nicht entschieden aber wir gehen davon
aus dass er den ministerposten nicht
bekommen und statt dessen eine auch hier
nicht vorkommende frau dieses
ministerium bekommen könnt maxi schon
namen nennen ist auch viel über frau
kipping diskutiert sächsische
gesundheitsminister die sächsische
gesundheitsministerin
darüber wird spekuliert allerdings wie
gesagt erst beim parteitag sollen die
namen stehen vielleicht noch zwei drei
namen die wir hier schon aufgeführt
haben also einmal vielleicht ganz kurz
bei der spd bleiben christine lambrecht
lamprecht auch dass die geschichte du
hast das gesagt nicht beschlossen aber
es ist davon auszugehen dass sie davon
ausgehen horst seehofer das
innenministerium landet auch ganz
spannend die geschichte die union
wirklich hat sich darüber ja zwei
jahrzehnte breitgemacht nach otto schily
in dem innenministerium ja das ist
schwarz durch und durch und das wird
jetzt auch zu einem roten minister und
sie muss es irgendwie aufräumen oder sie
wird aufgefressen von den schwarzen
beamten dort das wird sehr interessant
zu sehen sein aber sie hatten guten job
gemacht als justizministerin und
deswegen traut man ihr zu dass sie
inneres kann aber auch hier der name
noch nicht festgelegt einen haben wir
noch von der fdp kw ist volker wissing
der general der soll verkehrsminister
werden das eigentlich eine der grössten
überraschung nämlich mann war davon
ausgegangen dass er hier anton hofreiter
da drauf gehen wird aber der wird nicht
der soll ein anderes ministerium
bekommen und wissen wir schon was wo
wird anton hofreiter landen in der
landwirtschaft glaube ich eine
möglicherweise in der landwirtschaft
genau das sehen wir jetzt hier nicht auf
das verein wird das ein kombiniertes
ministerium mit der umwelt wird umwelt
einzeln sein weiß man das schon weil das
war ja zuletzt auch umstrittene was sich
lima kommt zur wirtschaft deswegen ist
unklar was sozusagen von umwelt bleibt
bauen und wohnen soll neu werden
entwicklung ist klar dass es bleibt und
wir wissen außerdem weitere namen die
hier nicht stehen die leer ausgehen
marie agnes strack zimmermann die wurde
gehandelt als verteidigungsministerin in
den vergangenen tagen das wird sie aber
nicht sie bekommt gar nix verteidigung
geht an die spd und da wird spannend wer
wird verteidigungsminister
okay das machen wir hier nochmal ein
fragezeichen drin auch das
gesundheitsministerium ich dass beide
rot wird es klar noch nicht vergeben
auch das bildungsministerium also dass
der aktuelle stand mit ein bisschen
ungewissheiten noch hier zum beispiel
bei arbeit und sozialen da können wir
aber relativ sicher von hubertus heil
ausgehend innenministerium können wir
relativ sicher von christine lambrecht
ausgehen und ansonsten sind das die
namen die wir ihnen heute verkünden
können die paul ronzheimer hier
mitgebracht hat also das sind die stühle
die aktuell am neuen kabinettstisch von
olaf scholz besetzt sind alles andere
bringt sehr wahrscheinlich dieser tag
noch hierbei bild live
ja das ist also die neue regierung oder
so viel wie wir schon von ihr wissen und
darüber müssen wir hier natürlich weiter
reden jan fleischhauer ist uns jetzt
zugeschaltet kolumnist mit ihm wollen
wir mal die ersten ministerposten wieso
durchgesickert sind diskutieren schön
dass sie bei uns sind was ist denn für
sie zum jetzigen zeitpunkt die größte
überraschung
vizekanzler robert habeck jemand also
für eine regierung die sie auf die fahne
geschrieben hat dass die frauen mir
vorkommen sollen also ich habe mich doch
gleich gefragt was ist mit
bundespräsidentin mit herrn steinmeier
also nochmal eins kann es oder bundes
jemand ein mann kanzler mann und
defizite ist auch ein mann ich finde da
muss einem ja
das ist tatsächlich eine erstaunliche
geschichte dieser ampel koalition wo man
ja 50 50 besetzen wollte jetzt hat man
drei männer eben vorne und dafür hat man
ja offenbar annalena baerbock das
außenministerium versprochen freuen sie
sich darüber
also es gibt viel spott und häme über
anderen in hamburg und ich gebe
natürlich zu für mich war es ein
gottesgeschenk als komponist im sommer
im wahlkampf aber
in der sache muss ich mal sagen
finde ich die position der grünen jetzt
nicht so unsympathisch eine
aussenpolitik also die haben einen
relativ klaren blick auf diktaturen wie
china und auch so ein autokratisches
system wie russland anders als die
sozialdemokraten und insofern wenn
annalena baerbock da die grünen linie
treu bleibt finde ich persönlich das
nicht das schlechteste was uns passieren
kann eine außenministerin an den
nürburgring
da wird finanzminister deshalb sehe
nämlich an nicht wahr
das freut mich natürlich weil das ist
für mich eine gewisse garantie ja das so
dieser dieser leichte ausweg
ins entweder geld pumpen oder geld bei
den reichen nehmen bis zu schön heißt
nicht gefunden werden kann so dass diese
regierung muss ich jetzt zum ersten mal
über etwas gedanken machen was politiker
natürlich hassen wie die pest sparen
vielleicht ja wer ist der größte
verlierer die grösste verliererin und
der größte gewinner oder die grösste
gewinnerin aus ihrer sicht bei den namen
die wir jetzt gesehen haben
wir wissen noch nicht so ganz genau wer
da so werde jetzt so leer ausgeht ist
haben sie ja gerade auch beschrieben da
eine an ratinger resthoffnung karl
lauterbach
gut da wenn
das natürlich schon bitter ich meine in
jeder talkshow deutschland sitzen ja das
gesicht
der regierung der alten schon in der
gesundheitspolitik ja das tapfer
durchgefochten und am ende leer ausgehen
weil
gut die eine wahrheit ist eine frau
brauchen die andere wache natürlich auch
dass sie ihnen in der spd hessen wie die
pest warum ist das so herr leute aber
weil er ist ja in der bevölkerung
umstritten aber es gibt ja gerade bei
denjenigen wenn man sich das so anschaut
am wochenende twitter das ist nicht
deutschland aber da hat die mehr
geschrieben wir wollen k das ist wie
gaal gegangen und auch karl lauterbach
hat sich darüber sehr gefreut in den
vergangenen tag und damit auch gekämpft
in seiner partei und wenn man sich die
umfragewerte anschaut dann muss man sagt
es zumindest mal jemand den deutschland
schon kennt ich werde viel karl
lauterbach also damit schützt man nicht
missverstehen ich finde man super typ ja
ich mag exzentriker also jemand der aus
heiterem himmel beschließt vor 30 jahren
auf salz lose kost umzustellen oder ist
für irgendein so zu sagen wir mal
irgendeinen grund gibt außer dass man
sich das im kopf gesetzt hat und das
auch durchziehen findet schon mal super
ich muss gestehen ich meinen sohn zum
beispiel war war ihm mitarbeiter sowie
der bundestagsfraktion also als er sein
praktikum brauchte als jurist hat er kam
sofort mitgemacht also ich bin sozusagen
auch da verpflichtet
hineinpassten jetzt erfahren können sie
denn hier auch gleich
gut dass sie sich für mich als und
durchdenken und ich glaube das ist das
problem relativ bei lauterbach er es im
grunde für politik zu exzentrisch und
parteien mögen
letztlich den funktionärs typ ja er
hatte ja schon überhaupt
der ist ja auch gar keine liste mehr
gekommen im bundestagswahlkampf ich
glaube haben die und auf platz 26 nach
hinten durchgereicht gemeinde
wahrscheinlich den bekanntesten
sozialdemokraten nach olaf scholz
aber er hat ja fed sein wahlkreis dann
ja also das seien leute verlassen aber
wenn sie sagen karl lauterbach ist ein
toller typ wünschen sie sich ihn als
minister als kolumnist oder weil sie
olaf
scholz können das haar das er im stress
mit dem man
gut durch als gründe müssten sie auch
schon mal toll
ich lebe natürlich von leuten die man
kennt ach so es braucht ja wahnsinnig
lange in der politik überhaupt bekannt
aufzubauen es gibt ja heute immer noch
knapp 66 die bevölkerung die sagen
angela merkel keine ahnung
heiko maas zum schluss da haben 14 der
deutschen freiwillig zugegeben umfang
das in dieser name unbekannt ist daran
können wir erkennen das braurecht lange
also da liegt natürlich lauterbach ganz
ganz vorne wichtiger posten
lauterbach sagte ich jetzt auch als
wichtiger posten auch der des
verteidigungsministers und den soll die
spd bekommen aber die machen momentan
noch ein geheimnis darum wer das denn
werden könnte wer ist aus ihrer sicht
geeignet bei der spd
verteidigungsminister oder
verteidigungsministerin zu werden da
kenne ich überhaupt nicht aus ich habe
jetzt das wird
es wird unter anderem auch heiko maas
wieder gehandelt was man sich nicht so
richtig vorstellen kann angesichts
dessen dass er dann noch mal ein
untersuchungsausschuss muss zum thema
afghanistan aber wenn man sich in der
spd umhört dann hört man auch na ja der
hat zumindest minister frau
ruth die die bundeswehr ist schon sehr
weit unten dann ist sie fertig
damit man sagt also heiko maas als
verteidigungsminister dann immer da kann
man doch da kann man das her doch
abschaffen dann bleibt nichts mehr übrig
oder oder gibt es da widersprechen meine
der mantel sind wie wir wissen in
afghanistan als verteidiger des freien
westens empfohlen hat ja
jetzt denke ich wir haben da gibt es den
begriff machst machst
fahnenflucht ist wie bisher heute eher
fleischer um 15 uhr geht es ja nicht nur
um posten sondern es geht ja auch um
inhalte was muss in ihrer ansicht nach
unbedingt im koalitionsvertrag stehen
ich habe
ja schon wenn keine steuern erhoben
werden was ja groß angekündigt war und
man die schuldenbremse so einigermaßen
einhält und jetzt nirgendwo
schattenhaushalte überall bildet um den
riesigen vorhaben zu finanzieren oder
ansonsten ich damit meine das was die
ampel vorgestellt hat das lang- und wir
haben ja das untier und papier gesehen
da stand ja im wesentlichen darin auch
was man sich schon mal einigen konnte
das ist glaube ich ein programm mit dem
die meisten menschen in deutschland
gehen können so also es gibt also die
mehrheit gottlob
will jetzt nicht dass überall die
steuern erhoben werden das ist kraft
aber die mehrheit hat auch nichts gegen
mindestlohn und die hat auch nichts
gegen die reform des ausländerrechts
und ich glaube insofern das ist
letztlich es ist eine
sozialdemokratische regierung wie wir
sie die letzten 16 jahre hatten
glauben sie dass olaf scholz da noch
vorkommen zwischen den ganzen stars
robert habeck der strahlt christian
lindner der strahlt annalena baerbock
die vielleicht auch mal irgendwann
wieder strahlt oder auf stolze habe ich
gar keine sorge
die deutschen haben doch offenbar auch
sein faible für so diesen typus also dem
denen jetzt sozusagen nicht frau mit
raute sondern man mit raute
das hat er schon gezeigt dass kann er
also kurz über das warum haben die leute
gewählt weil er am glaubhaftesten
das konkret kontinuum versprochen hat so
also einfach merkel ohne merkel vier
jahre weiter so damit ist der
koalitionsvertrag geschrieben von focus
kolumnist jan fleischhauer danke für das
launige gespräch hierbei live